hey guys how's it going today we're
having a party for Matt it's his
birthday in a few days and Jenna got him
this incredible cake wait till you see
it it's got a little Charizard on it
Matt's little name what do you think
your cake I love it it's unbelievable I
cannot believe you guys got that done
for me you you're nice to me that was
all Jenna I just I'm just here I'm gonna
make a nice little fruit salad for the
party to be a little healthy so I have a
series of videos coming out and in one
of these videos I cut a pineapple for
the first time ever so when you see that
video and you see me saying I'm cutting
a pineapple for the first time I
actually am I got a little something at
the grocery store Jenna called with the
pineapple pump let's figure it out so
I'm gonna cut this plan out pretty
exciting do I just like what do i how do
i okay you hold the pineapple is no
pinching me know what this look like
when I get all of it hey Matt do you
like pineapple you don't see you're
gonna have a pretty impressive can you
grab that is it at the bottom now yeah
I've been through the pineapple how do
you know it's too bad you cut the hole
cuz you could use this as a drinking
beverage oh I know how do I get this off
of here now always look at this I just
slide this freakin pineapple right there
pretty cool maybe I will cut this
watermelon so I can close the lid thank
you
crimes in there is not toasted well how
dare you not toast the pibatch mmm
knocking oh no not that so what about
requests was to make jello shots and we
didn't make them yet and I'm not ready
but we can make jello shots pretty
quickly I just looked it up online
well it's not on the jello package one
cup boiling water well I think it's
fixed
okay well the water's boiling need one
cup of cold water empty jello powder
into large mixing bowl and add boiling
water okay Barba's wolf the genie
stirring for two minutes
how many just start continue okay
what sorry stars down okay oh this is
there on two minutes
shouldn't you be the boughs at the same
time give me two packs are we doing two
packs
okay now I'll add 1/2 cup cold water and
1/2 cup vodka stir until mix and pour in
two ounces two ounce cups don't ask me
what just put them in here yeah about
that rubble water all right start the
night around okay boiling okay you put
it in there what put the put that look
put it in there I want to help I want to
put that in there I'm an expert because
uh oatmeal wait this is only
vodka okay Dwight mixes with water vodka
and water yes those men after it's
dissolved from the market from the vodka
I'm looking at your bum you definite
Philips clothes in here
not these four these are okay but all
the others do these lungs because
they're like bolted in oh I wonder what
boy at this party I could convince
figure out how to install things you
trust not maybe not maven I might trust
them are okay because they're excited to
use this tripod players your farm is
hello oh boy do it we're gonna we're
gonna edit that out we're not we're
gonna leave it in it's so hot my air
conditioning isn't working and I don't
want to fix it what
that's what they do each day
Oh Jason I'm so excited about this talus
tration yeah this game is awful the
worst name is not my brothers one person
isn't here in a while no I thought you
liked no he's usually we were like
working and just like hanging out is
weird
more like for a month straight
yeah
but even more importantly look what ed
and Allison made they made Lego
starburst ice cubes you put some
starburst into it and then you put that
in your oven and you bake it for about
15-20 minutes 350 degrees then you put
it into
it's cool all the other gear for one 500
maybe we beat you twice happy birthday
from Mama and Papa morning uh Wow great
party last night I'm not even sure if
I've logged anything hey Matt did you
have a fun party look great
oh you're vlogging yeah you look yeah
you don't have to say anything I want to
come and do the vlog
okay commandeering ah I'm Captain Jack
Sparrow and I'm still drunk i
commandeered you get it that's like a
pirate term that's why I say ahead
Captain Jack Sparrow did you get it yeah
have you watch my future I think maybe
like one of them isn't there for you
yeah look I'm making french toast
oh you put the your nose so we've been
doing a little you know home renovation
type thing like just trying to get
furniture and something that we never
have is what Jenna well we only never
have a measuring tape because we give it
back why do we need to good this isn't
for me need a major some things so I'm
pretty excited about it yeah how long do
you think this is conscious no that's
not just the water everywhere oh you
give me that okay back to measuring
clothes which is
feet that's what I said yeah but you
didn't see the itches all right well
thanks for watching them in the edit
this vlog Nowlin measure some things
hope you guys are doing well
bye I'm the DJ good boo my time DJ yes
good boy you're very very good ready
time to DJ